The Neverending Story gave a generation
a world of dreams and Imagination but
unfortunately some stories do have an
end these actors from the films are
sadly no longer with us the wonderful
adventures and The Neverending Story
wouldn't have even begun if Bastian
hadn't stumbled into the bookstore owned
by cranky Carl Conrad coriander
portrayed by Thomas Hill the video
arcade is down the street here we just
sell small rectangular objects they're
called books over the years Hill played
a wide range of characters in many
television series and film films most
notably the recurring role of Jim Dixon
in the classic CBS sitcom newart however
he returned to the role of the ordinary
book seller he had created six years
prior in 1990s the never- Ending Story 2
the next chapter on April 20th 2009 the
81-year-old actor died from a heart
attack but he will always be remembered
as the gruff old man who inspired a
world of children to crack open a book
Moses Gun memorably portrayed The Herald
of the childlike Empress who sends a
tryu on his quest to save Fantasia is
there any chance of success
I do not know aside from The Neverending
Story gun featured in a number of
prominent roles in film and television
including Sha's arch nemesis bumpy Jonas
and shaft and shaft's Big Score he was
also nominated for an Emmy for his
portrayal of kintango and ABC's 1977
miniseries Roots his success wasn't just
limited to the screen either for his
stage work he won an Obi award in 1968
for playing Aaron in Titus andronicus
and he was nominated for a Tony in 1976
for portraying Benjamin hpo in the
poison Tree on December 16th 1993 the
64-year-old actor died from asthma
complications leaving behind a wealth of
treasured performances played by
Patricia Hayes urgle is a gnome who
spends most of her time making gross
broths and bickering with her husband
Eng now it's my turn with him oh no
you
don't I decide when he's well it's your
turn when I say it's your turn appearing
in films and television since 1936 Hayes
AC Creed over 130 acting credits to her
name including roles in the fantasy film
Willow and the comedy classic of Fish
Called Wanda she also appeared in
television Classics like BBC's the Benny
Hill show till death us Dart and
spooners Patch her role in a 1971
episode of the BBC Anthology series play
for today snagged her up after win on
September 19th 1998 Hayes died due to
natural causes at the age of 88 Sydney
Bramley gave a memorable performance as
zok in the never- Ending Story imbuing
The Scientist gnome with the perfect
balance of comedic chaos and dramatic
gravitas the character's knowledge of
the Southern Oracle helps a tray you
further along on his quest to save the
empress have you ever been to the
southern
Oracle what do you think throughout a
career that spanned over 50 years
Bramley found himself in roles that were
just as Fantastical and adventurous he
was also in other Fantasy Classics like
the 1981 Epic Dragon Slayer and 1986's
pirates on August 14th 1987 Bramley died
at the age of 78 but his work will be
remembered as a gateway to Adventure for
many played by tilo pner the nigh hob is
one of the first Fantastical creatures
we meet in the never- Ending Story is he
a nutcase no he's a rock biter a rock
biter a rock biter well internationally
pner is most likely known for playing
the nighthob he has acted in over 200
German films and television series
dating from 1967 all the way through
2021 he also wrote and published his
only novel in 2013 which told the story
of a doctor in a failing relationship on
July 2nd 2020 Brookner died of heart
failure at the age of 79 ending a truly
remarkable career perhaps the most emot
Al devastating scene in The Never Ending
Story or any movie for that matter is
when a treyus horse arac it comes to
Despair and drowns in the swamp of
sadness
artex fight against the sadness artex
the scene is so powerful and convincing
that it led to a persistent rumor that
the filmmakers actually drowned the
horse on set which isn't true in
actuality two horses were trying to go
up to their necks in water and were
frequently swapped out while filming to
not overwhelm them the horses were never
fully submerged as is evident in the
finished film after filming was complete
one of the horses was gifted to the
actor playing a treay you Noah Hathaway
however due to how complicated it would
be to ship to his home hathway decided
to leave the horse in Germany with his
stunt riding double the horse lived on
his Ranch for the next 20 years or so
before passing released 6 years after
the 1984 original the never- Ending
Story 2 the next chapter was in need of
a younger actor to play Bastion the role
originally portrayed by Barrett Oliver
Jonathan Brandis stepped in to fill the
role and told the story of Bastion
returning to again save Fantasia is
there no with the courage to stand up
with me against the Giants prior to the
sequel Brandis had mostly appeared in
small television roles afterward he
quickly found himself in a ton of higher
profile roles throughout the early 90s
those included Stephen King's It Rodney
dangerfields 1992 Sports comedy ladybugs
and the 1992 Chuck Norris karate comedy
Sidekicks but he truly became a
certified Teen Idol when he was cast as
the scientific genius Lucas and NBC
Sci-Fi Action series sequest dsv
tragically on November 12th 2003 Brandis
died by by Suicide at the age of 27
Freddy Jones does double duty in the
never- Ending Story 3 playing the old
man of wandering Mountain as well as
taking over the role of Mr
coriander the old man of wandering
Mountain was the author of The never-
Ending Story in the original novel but
here he functions more as its protector
as a book basically writes itself that
is until some bullies steal the book
from Cory ander's library and start
writing a new future throughout his
nearly 60-year career Jones appeared in
over 200 film and television projects
these included big films like 1983's
koll 1985's Young Sherlock Holmes and
2002's account of Monte Christo he also
featured in three David Lynch films Dune
the Elephant Man and Wild at Heart his
final role was a 13-year run of Sandy
Thomas on the ITV soap opera emerdale on
July 9th 2019 Jones died at the age of
91 leaving behind a wife and three sons
including Harry Potter and Marvel Alum
Toby Jones falor the luck dragon was
voiced by a different actor in all three
films in the never- Ending Story 3 the
Fluffy and lovable character was voiced
by fan convention Mainstay William
hootkins oh no I'm losing out atude
look hookin appeared in over 100
projects including 1981's Raiders of the
Lost Arc and 1989's Batman but he was
probably best recognized for flying his
X-Wing in the Battle of Yavin under the
call sign red six and the 1977 classic
Star Wars that's right hins was the fan
favorite rebel pilot Jack tono Porkins
on October 2
2005 hins died of pancreatic cancer at
the age of 57 in the never-ending Story
3 Fantasia is threatened by a group of
bullies calling themselves the nasties
each nasty has their role in the group
and the muscle was provided by rage
beefy portrayed by Adrien
dorville over the years dorville
contributed his talents to a wide range
of popular television series usually in
small parts that includes MacGyver
Highlander the 2004 Battle Star
Galactica Stargate sg1 and more on the
feature film side he popped up in
Shanghai Noon and the Chronicles Ric to
name a few on January 5th 2021 dwell
died from cancer at the age of 57 in the
never- Ending Story 3 the childlike
empress and the old man of wandering
Mountain are assisted in their quest to
Fantasia by a character known only as
large head I was able to butt us through
to the secret Tunnels for our Escape
well that's using your head when the
nine days actor Thomas Petro was on set
he would spend over 4 hours in making up
each morning to achieve the bulbous
headed look of the character while he
has a few other on-screen credits to his
name Petro put a much larger stamp on
the world of voice acting specifically
he dubbed over 2,000 films into his
native German notable instances include
providing the voice for Biff tannin and
all of the Back to the Future films
dubbing over Gary Oldman in four
separate films and voicing Sheldon
Plankton in the Nickelodeon television
series SpongeBob
SquarePants
on April 13th 2018 Petro died at the age
of 61 leaving behind a lifetime of
voices at the beginning to the first
never- Ending Story Bastion finds
himself on the run from a handful of
bullies just before he makes it to the
bookstore Bastion Ducks past two men on
the sidewalk causing one of them to drop
a bottle of milk it's actually a sneaky
Cameo the guy who drops the milk is
played by the film's director wolf game
Peterson who went on to direct films
like Air Force One The Perfect Storm and
Troy the man next to him is burn ainger
the producer of the never- ending story
ainger produced a wide range of films
including four Resident Evil films the
first two Fantastic Four films and the
Shan connory Christian Slater film the
name of the Rose in addition to
producing he was also an accomplished
screenwriter having written 2006's
perfume the story of a murderer about a
scent obsessed serial killer and 2004's
downfall about the rise and fall of
Hitler the latter received an Oscar
nomination and thousands of re subtitled
Hitler rant parodies tragically they
both passed at the age of 61 after
having worked on nearly 100 films ainger
died of a heart attack on January 24th
2011 Peterson died on August 12th 2022
from pancreatic cancer he was
[Music]